den rhein runter fährt kann man ab 40
burgen und schlössern vorbei auf 65
kilometern das ist einmalig auf der welt
du könntest hierunter die reiseführer
mag ich wusste gar nicht dass du da
qualitäten hast du bist wahrscheinlich
vieles nicht von mir ich weiß vor allem
eins ich hab hunger ich auch wo ist die
pickel tasche aber wollen wir nicht
lieber in der stadt essen
ich habe gehört dass die museumsmeile
die schon toll aber das ist mit dem
jedoch gar nicht zu vergleichen
das wichtigste ist dass unsere hungrigen
bei euch erst mal was zu essen kriegen
was willst du denn da kommt früh genug
in die stadt
schau dir das an diese weinberge
vielleicht haben wollte noch eine
weinprobe machen gute idee wenn wir mehr
zeit haben ich bin auch hungrig aber
lasst mich noch zwei drei fotos machen
so reza du noch ein bisschen mehr nach
links zu lehnen und du magst nicht so
böse
du bist nicht mit auf dem foto
das ist also sozusagen der berühmteste
sohn der stadt
ludwig van beethoven wenn ihr wollt
können wir noch zusammen geburtshaus
gehen das ist gleich da drüben
ich würde ja lieber auf die museums aber
wir gehen natürlich zuerst in beethovens
und vorher gebe ich euch allen noch ein
eis haus
es muss man rucksack